it's an emotional time in my life for
sure I've been I'm having a lot of cries
lately it's been a rollercoaster ride
for Justin Bieber over the past few
years but a source tells et he and Haley
are gearing up for the event of their
lives and the wet later this month in
South Carolina we have a good time
together
he's just really sweet he's a good kid a
good heart of course the couple has been
legally married since last September but
our source says they want to celebrate
their love and unity in front of the
people they love especially God I
believe it's not my job to push anything
that I believe on anyone else you know I
think it's just my job to be a light and
share what I've been what I went through
as far as my spiritual my spiritual
journey
justin has been on his own spiritual
journey last week he performed at his
church our source says they want their
wedding to be private but that it'll be
a fairy tale with over-the-top flowers
and lights and to expect an all around
party for their loved ones if your core
foundation isn't supporting you then
you're just gonna you're just not gonna
be balanced you're not gonna have that
anchor to make sure you have a you know
I'm trying to say Justin's been candid
about his struggles with mental health
recently but our source says quote
Justin is going into his upcoming
wedding weekend in a very good place
looking forward to showing everyone the
love he and Hailey share I'm just
learning more how to navigate through
situations better and how to like just
be myself
[Music]
[Applause]